when someone comes up to me and says you
know I want to be a filmmaker I want to
be an actor
um you know I'm trying to talk to my
parents what do you think what should I
do and all this stuff and I I'm like if
there's a choice involved don't do it if
there's no other way there's just no
other way I said imagine You've Lost
Your the person needs you love you your
parents I think you're you're you know a
failure your everything has gone wrong
everything do you still want to be a and
it takes 20 years 30 years and everybody
says you stink you stink you're terrible
if you spent all that time I'll regret
your whole life is defined by your
failure to do this is it still something
you want to do then go do it because it
should be no other choice in the matter
it takes like an irrational passion to
do it you can there will be those people
that kind of do the process and then get
lucky and fall into it but I don't want
to watch movies by those people I want
to watch movies by the people that there
was no other choice